خطه الصين لسلام في اوكرانيا بين التشكيك
والقبول والرفض موقف واشنطن بدا متململا
الخارجيه الامريكيه شككت في الخطه بدايه
قبل ان يخرج بايضا ويعلن رفضه لها صراحه
اذا كان بوتين يصفق لها فكيف يمكن ان تكون
جيده انا لا اريد ان اكون طريفا انا جاد
للغايه لم ارى شيئا في الخطه يشير الى
انها ستكون مفيده لاي احد اخر غير روسيا
والفرنسي ايمانويل الذي اعلن انه سيزور
الصين مطلع الشهر المقبل اكد ان السلام
ممكن واصفا جهود بيكين بالامر الجيد لافتا
الى دورها في الضغط على روسيا
ياتي ذلك غداه نقل صحيفه جورنال عن مصادر
ان باريس ولندن ابلغت الرئيس الاوكراني
فولو ديميرزلينسكي بضروره الاخذ بعين
الاعتبار مفاوضات السلام
زيلينسكي رحب ببعض عناصر المقترح الصيني
لوقف اطلاق النار لكنه قال ان الدوله التي
تدور فيها الحرب هي التي ينبغي ان تطلق
خطه السلام ان كانت هناك افكار تتوافق
بطريقه او باخرى مع احترام القانون الدولي
وسلامه الاراضي فلنعمل مع الصين في هذه
النقطه من جهتها قالت روسيا حليفه الصين
انها تقدر جهود بيكين لوضع حد للنزاع مع
تشديدها على ضروره الاعتراف بضم موسكو
لاربع مناطق اوكرانيه تطالب بها
المندوب الروسي لدى مجلس الامن قال ايضا
ان وضع حد للاعمال القتاليه في اوكرانيا
سيسمح للعالم بالتعافي اما الامم المتحده
فقد اعتبرت خارطه السلام الصينيه بشان
اوكرانيا مساهمه مهمه خطه الصين تحث كلا
الجانبين على الاتفاق على خفض تدريجي
للتصعيد وتحذر من استخدام الاسلحه النوويه
بلال الوجداني العربيه